[Música]
[Aplausos]
nosotros vamos ahora a conversar con
nuestro primer invitado del día sobre la
huelga de guionistas de Hollywood que
avanza a medida que fracasan las
negociaciones entre los grandes estudios
y el writers guild of America el
sindicato que congrega a 11.500
trabajadores en paro desde el 2 de mayo
Cuáles son los efectos de esta huelga
hay una solución a la vista ahora lo
analizamos con Felipe Torres Medina él
es escritor y guionista de televisión
actualmente guionista para the Lake show
Y también como miembro del sindicato de
guionistas desde 2019 está hoy en
Noruega Felipe Buenos días para usted
muchas gracias por acompañarnos aquí en
el directo América en France 24
Buenos días Gracias por tenerme Felipe
le pido para nosotros y nuestra
audiencia una breve contexto sobre la
situaciones que desencadenaron esta
huelga no
Bueno lo que sucede es que estamos
negociando Como cada tres años
el sindicato negocia con una alianza de
productoras que incluye más de
trescientas
productoras aquí en los Estados Unidos
el contrato de lo que llamamos el mínimo
en que es el contrato de acuerdos
mínimos es decir los pagos mínimos y
esas negociaciones Lamentablemente
fracasaron y por eso entramos en huelga
el primero de mayo Y Felipe sí lo que
vendría a ser digamos un convenio
colectivo no podríamos decir y qué es
exactamente qué condiciones se piden
usted que se mejoren y que es lo que no
aceptan los grandes estudios Cuáles son
los puntos irreconciliables que ahora
mismo evitan que se llegue a un acuerdo
bueno lo único que estamos pidiendo Es
compartir el éxito del contenido que
creamos la el streaming y las series y
las películas que creamos están dándole
récords de ingresos a las compañías Y en
especial récords de pagos a los de estas
compañías Mientras tanto el pago semanal
de los escritores ha caído en un 4%
desde el 2018 y cuando se ajuste para la
inflación eso es un 23%
estamos hablando de que el 33% de los
escritores que escriben en series Se les
paga el mínimo que debe que se les
pagaba el mínimo que debía pagarse hace
diez años hoy en día somos casi la mitad
que trabajamos por el mínimo que se le
debe pagar el pago en promedio de los
guionistas no ha aumentado desde el 2018
son muchísimos temas como eso y además
la la transición al streaming ha causado
que el pago a los escritores de cine de
películas se les pague muchísimo menos
den mucho más trabajo gratis y a los
escritores de comedia y variedades como
yo nosotros no tenemos un pago mínimo
para shows que se emiten en streaming
Entonces el día que decidan mover todos
nuestros streaming como la industria se
está moviendo podrían empezar a pagarnos
lo que ellos quieran Sí y le pregunto
Cuál es precisamente la reacción de los
grandes estudios a sus demandas
tristemente la reacción fue ni siquiera
negociar Nosotros llegamos a negociar en
buena fe con propuestas muy bien
pensadas Nosotros tenemos un comité
negociador que nos mostró todas las
propuestas antes de
ir a negociar con con las productoras y
ellos respondieron de manera casi que un
poco insultante la verdad O sea Ellos
nos dijeron nos respondieron algunas de
las propuestas y a otras ni siquiera se
dignaron a responder
si uno mira el sindicato sacó una un
documento que tiene la lista de lo que
pedimos y lo que ellos respondieran y en
la columna de lo que ellos respondieron
son cinco seis propuestas que nosotros
enviamos que dice no hubo contraoferta
ni siquiera se dignaron a responder
Felipe y precisamente el trabajo de los
guionistas a menudo Pues a no queda no
está muy reflejado no la gente al final
ve el trabajo de los actores en la
pantalla y rara vez somos conscientes de
todo el trabajo que hay detrás en lo que
es la escritura de las producciones le
pregunto que nos explique un poco cómo
funciona este este trabajo Cuántos por
ejemplo guionistas trabajan en el late
show donde usted donde esté está
empleado actualmente y si este trabajo
podría ser sustituido por la
Inteligencia artificial como se plantea
no en esta discusión que es una
herramienta la que quieren recurrir los
grandes estudios
Sí en mi show trabajamos en el que yo
trabajo trabajamos 20 24 escritores más
o menos
es esta es otra de las cosas que estamos
pidiendo es mínimos para número de
escritores porque poder establecer esos
mínimos permite que los showrunners que
es la digamos el título más alto en
términos de escritura tenga que pueda
concentrarse en manejar el show Y menos
en tener que hacer reescrituras y
trabajo que podrían hacer otros
escritores pero los servicios de
streaming y las productoras cada vez
están reduciendo y reduciendo y
reduciendo el tamaño de las salas de
escritores para que haya menos
escritores más trabajo básicamente
ser más efectivos con los fondos lo que
eso significa es que los y que los
escritores que existen tienen que
trabajar menos
y cuál sería La amenaza o cómo quieren
sustituirlos a ustedes con la
Inteligencia artificial tal y como se
está denunciando brevemente porque nos
quedamos Lamentablemente sin tiempo
Sí nosotros básicamente lo que le
dijimos a las productoras es que
queríamos que si la Inteligencia
artificial se va a utilizar como
herramienta que nosotros no somos
digamos anti tecnología que la
Inteligencia artificial No puede
escribir no puede quedar con el crédito
de autoridad que nos parecía algo muy
razonable las productoras simplemente
respondieron que no que no querían
amordazarse a eso y que querían hablar
de tecnología una vez al año básicamente
no es un temor de que nos reemplacen es
un temor de que la calidad se va a
reducir porque
como se ha demostrado la Inteligencia
artificial no está en este momento un
punto donde pueda hablar y escribir
cosas lógicas y cosas con con digamos
sutileza Exacto sí menos todavía Pues un
contenido no que después es artes y
atrapa a millones de personas alrededor
del mundo y forma parte de la cultura de
nuestros días Felipe Muchas gracias por
compartir su experiencia aquí en France
24 con nosotros estaremos muy atentos a
esta huelga como avanza Y cómo avanzan
estas negociaciones
Gracias por invitarme a usted Y ustedes
sigan con nosotros que enseguida
volvemos con más información
[Música]